aproximación del inciso a estaba
sobreestimada o subestimada en la
cantidad de residuo que tiene mi
contenedor después del tiempo te iguala
un cuarto ahora sí después muy
refrigerio y un buen vaso con agua es
hora de seguir trabajando entonces que
dice la primera parte de ese problema
calcula la segunda derivada de w con
respecto al tiempo en términos de w pero
recuerden que el primer vídeo nosotros
teníamos aquí la primera derivada del w
con respecto al tiempo entonces si la
primera derivada de w con respecto el
tiempo es decir w prima de t era un 25
por w de t menos 300 entonces cómo
quedará w prima de t pues bueno para
obtenerla hay que derivar w prima con
respecto al tiempo otra vez y como se
derivar esta función pues bueno primero
voy a multiplicar el 125 por w dt y
después real multiplicar el un 25 ago
por 300 a un 25 por w de t su derivada
es un 25 ago por w prima de t ojo
recuerden que como w de t es una función
entonces su derivada
la prima de té bien entonces habíamos
multiplicado en un 25 por w de té y
después que habíamos multiplicado es de
un 25 por 300 pero 300 entre 25 212 y
que creen la derivada de 12 ese bar es
una constante entonces aunque estamos
derivando con respecto al tiempo cuando
derivamos 12 o cualquier constante la
derivada es 0 por lo tanto ya acabamos
la segunda derivada de w con respecto al
tiempo es un 25 agua de la primera
derivada de w con respecto al tiempo
pero ojo no es la respuesta de la
primera de la primera parte de este
problema porque me piden que dé la
respuesta en términos de w y hasta
ahorita yo tengo la segunda derivada en
términos de la primera derivada por lo
tanto voy a sustituir lo que valía la
primera derivada que teníamos en esta
igualdad entonces me va a quedar un 25
ago de w prima de t pero doble un prima
de tres aumentos incoado por w de t
menos 300 entonces solamente hay que
copiarlo de este lado y me va a quedar
un 25 años que multiplica a un 25 ago
que multiplica a su vez a w de t
300 y que creen aquí ya tengo a w de té
es decir ya tengo la respuesta que yo
quería esto lo puede simplificar un poco
w mi prima de té quién va a ser pues un
25 por un 25 agua es 1 625 agua entonces
1 625 agua que multiplica a w de menos
300 y en este momento ya tengo a la
segunda derivada expresada como términos
de la función original sin ninguna
derivada entonces ya tengo la respuesta
de mi primera parte la segunda derivada
de w con respecto al tiempo es un 625 a
bolas la función normal menos 300 ok
ahora vamos a hacer la segunda parte de
ese problema vamos a leer la dice usa la
segunda derivada de w con respecto al
tiempo para determinar si la respuesta
del inciso a estaba sobreestimada o
subestimada en la cantidad de residuo
que debes de tener en tu contenedor al
tiempo te iguala un cuarto entonces en
el in sexual lo que calculamos era la
pendiente de la recta tangente en w en
el tiempo te iguala 0 y cuando está
pendiente hicimos una aproximación de la
cantidad d
lo que debería de haber en el tiempo te
iguala un cuarto ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es comparar la pendiente en el
tiempo de igual a cero con la pendiente
en el tiempo de igual a un cuarto y si
los pendientes son iguales entonces la
aproximación fue exacta pero sin embargo
si la pendiente del tiempo te iguala un
cuarto aumenta entonces subestimamos la
aproximación y si la pendiente del
tiempo te iguala un cuarto disminuye
entonces sobre estimamos la aproximación
y para saber si la pendiente en el
tiempo te iguala un cuarto está
creciendo o disminuyendo o se queda
igual hay que fijarnos en el signo de la
segunda derivada si el signo de nuestra
segunda derivada es positivo quiere
decir que la pendiente aumentó y
estábamos subestimando nuestra
aproximación pero para hacerlo más claro
vamos a intentar dibujar supongamos que
esta es mi gráfica de w y que ésta es mi
recta tangente en el punto t igual a
cero nuestro primer caso va a ser que la
pendiente aumente si la pendiente
aumento es decir es creciente entonces
nosotros teníamos parados abajo del
valor real es decir habremos subestimado
la cantidad real
y lo que teníamos el segundo caso es que
las pendientes sean iguales es decir la
gráfica se vería algo así si las
pendientes son iguales entonces nuestra
aproximación fue muy buena porque la
aproximación que hicimos es el valor
real de la cantidad de residuo que hay
en el contenedor ahora sí nosotros
tenemos que la pendiente disminuyó bueno
eso no se podría porque sería una
función decreciente se dan cuenta si la
pendiente disminuye entonces la función
iría hacia abajo pero de todas maneras
para no quedarnos con la duda voy a
intentar dibujar lo y vamos a ver el
tercer caso que es que las pendientes
disminuyan y yo haya sobreestimado mi
aproximación entonces pintemos otra vez
todo de nuevo este es mi recta tangente
en el punto de igual a cero
bien y esta es mi función w y ya
habíamos dicho que si la pendiente en el
tiempo te iguala un cuarto había
aumentado entonces habíamos subestimado
la cantidad de residuo que iba a haber
en el tiempo te iguala un cuarto este va
a ser mi eje de las dobles mejor lo voy
a pintar un poco más derecho aquí está
el general w
este de aquí era la cantidad inicial mil
cuatrocientas toneladas y esta es mi eje
del tiempo entonces aquí en un cuarto en
el tiempo te iguala un cuarto nosotros
habíamos estimado la cantidad de mil 411
toneladas ahora bien si mis pendientes
son iguales si la pendiente no aumentos
simple y sencillamente se quedó igual
sería este caso y en este caso mi
aproximación sería el valor real de la
cantidad de residuo que hay en el
contenedor en el tiempo te iguala un
cuarto ahora qué pasaría si en lugar de
aumentar o ser igual la pendiente
disminuyera es decir será un caso como
este estilo pues entonces nuestra
cantidad hubiera sido sobreestimada es
decir tendríamos más cantidad de residuo
que la que en verdad es
bueno pero qué pasa con la segunda
derivada en este caso en el primer caso
cuando las pendientes aumentan la
segunda derivada tiene un signo positivo
es decir donde v prima tendrá signo
positivo si las pendientes aumentan en
el otro caso si los pendientes
disminuyen pues w prima o la segunda
derivada va a tener signo negativo
entonces si las pendientes disminuyen te
descienda negativo y en el segundo caso
si las pendientes son iguales entonces w
prima o la segunda derivada será cero si
la pendiente no aumenta disminuye la
segunda derivada va a ser cero pues
vamos a calcular entonces cuál es el
valor de la segunda derivada para
resolver la segunda parte de este
problema así que vamos a hacer las
cuentas que pasa con w y prima evaluado
en 0 w prima evaluado en 0 es igual a 1
625 a bo que multiplica a w evaluado en
0 que ya sabemos cuánto es menos 300
pero w evaluado en cero era 1.400
toneladas entonces lo voy a poner aquí
1.400 toneladas y 1400 menos 300 es lo
mismo que 1.100 toneladas entonces mil
100 toneladas
entre 625 quien sabe cuánto sea eso es
como 1 punto de infracción pero lo que
me importa es que es con signo positivo
1100 entre 625 tiene signo positivo por
lo tanto las pendientes están aumentando
estamos en el primer caso en el que las
pendientes están creciendo por lo tanto
tenemos una cantidad sub estimada lo que
nosotros calculamos en el inciso a era
una subestimación de lo que realmente es
el valor de la cantidad de residuo en el
contenedor entonces estamos en el primer
caso bien entonces ya tenemos la
respuesta de la segunda parte de este
problema la cantidad de residuo en el
contenedor que calculamos era
subestimada en el tiempo t igual a un
cuarto